that's to something
hey there i'm philip molina and holy
crap did you guys see this Suicide Squad
trailer I'm assuming so because you're
watching this video I will be the first
to say that it wasn't the most exciting
movie when we first heard about it /
when we first saw some pictures / when
we heard Will Smith say with some kind
of Suicide Squad I will say after this
trailer I don't know it kind of changes
things like whoever made this thing
Bravo this is one of the best other dude
trailers I've seen in a very long time
and I see a lot of freaking trailers and
yeah sure it has some similarities to
the guardians of the galaxy trailer with
anti-heroes escaping a prison and it's
set to a totally classic song full
whatever that trailer was great - and
that movie was great and I won't say
that Suicide Squad is like definitely
gonna be this amazing movie but you
can't deny after that trailer that it's
probably at least gonna be one of the
most fun movies of the year so how about
we dissect it all right let's do okay
right away we have to immediately
address this freaking epic song choice
for human Rhapsody's yeah it's an
amazing song but it's actually
incredibly appropriate it's pretty
obvious that the editor of this trailer
was using specific moments of the song
and its lyrics to really highlight
themes that this movie's gonna explore
like what's it mean to be evil can
someone who's killed a man find
redemption is that person's soul doom
yada yada theme theme that will get into
them as they come up but right here I'm
gonna point out just overall about the
song it's really famous for its very
diverse different sections that kind of
have no business being put together they
sound like completely different songs
and yet when you smash them together for
some reason they create one of the
greatest rock songs of all time
very very frightening
I think we'll go with a little bohemian
rhapsody' gentleman good call so overall
the creators of this movie are telling
us that this team has no business being
put together there's no reason why this
should work and yet they might actually
end up being one of the most epic teams
to have ever formed and yeah that's a
really high bar that they're setting but
they definitely seem to think they're
gonna deliver on that moving on the
opening lyrics introduce us to two
pretty opposite states of mind with is
this the real-life showing us the newest
inmates to the prison Jai Courtney's
Captain Boomerang beans tossed into a
solitary confinement cell and clearly
he's wondering yeah is this my real life
because if so that freaking sucks
this place is clearly no joke it's the
cells look like freakin shipping
container the guards load be ready to
pump inmates full of shotgun shells
if you jump back to the opening shot and
up the brightness a little bit you can
see that the prison's motto is firm but
fair and I think we can all pretty much
agree that that's probably BS and that
this place is probably just some sort of
living nightmare and speaking of living
in a dream that second lyric or is this
just fantasy it's introducing us to the
opposite state of mind instead of
accepting the harsh reality we have
Harley Quinn clearly seen herself in
some sort of fantasy situation she's
sipping tea her pinkies all dainty she's
reading a Harlequin romance novel which
yes I see what you did there clever the
job that book is actually called between
the sheets and it's a story of what
happens when an uptight straight-laced
woman meets this chaotic risk-taking bad
boy who teaches her how to lose control
and go a little crazy and it kind of
sounds familiar right also it's a very
good read but don't ask how I know that
before we move on I'll point out that
the jumpsuit says site Bravo which is
clearly a code name which would imply
that this is a secret prison that
probably isn't showing up on any Maps
anywhere but actually Bravo 14 was the
code name they used for this movie while
they were shooting it I'm moving on
Will Smith stares out of a window
watching rain fall and something tells
me that it's probably been a really long
time since he's felt rain on his skin
then Killer Croc does some push-ups in
his cell but let's crank up the
brightness and point out how much is
actually going on here this is not a
normal cell it's almost more like a
sewer and it has some sort of like
pollen for him to swim in and there's
freaking like meat and entrails hanging
in the corner croc is a cannibal so it
makes you wonder is that freaking human
meat like I know you wouldn't actually
think it would be but doesn't this seem
like the kind of prison where inmates
just die all the time and it would be
way cheaper than planning funeral
arrangements and it'll have the ship in
pigs or cows guts or anything for him it
could be human meat I don't know we get
a quick shot of El Diablo playing with
fire which helps us see all of his crazy
tats and these are actually real la gang
tattoos with me vida loca being a
reference to the gang way of life the
cobwebs represent a long prison term a
Grim Reaper's died because he's the
bringer of death and so you can probably
guess what he's counting on those tally
marks above the eyebrow it's people that
dead people he's he's a murderer
I think you get it uh-huh we then see
the inside of Selvi 108 and yeah that
freaking sucks just like the song says
right there at that moment there's
literally no escaping from this reality
all right look here I want a simple task
force of the most dangerous people on
the planet they're bad guys worst of the
worst
we then see the same rainstorm that
Deadshot was staring at but from the
opposite side of life and like not only
does the color palette completely change
from that cold and sickly blue and green
to a warm very golden hue but even the
window blinds indicate that this is what
life is like on the other side of prison
bars
Viola Davis is Amanda Waller gives us
the premise of the movie she wants to
assemble a task force made up of bad
guys worst of the worst
but she's stuffing her mouth with steak
and she's having this fancy dinner with
these high-ranking members of the
military
this is often a really subtle way to
imply just how detached or even
sometimes corrupt the people in charge
can be because they're all it's not
their lives they're risking we can have
interesting color choices check out what
DC's done with the logos here this is
the beginning of the hold neon color
upgrade from that gray color palette
that they use in the comic-con trailer
and there's two really cool things about
this one is that if you pause it you can
see where someone has tagged the logos
with neon graffiti and they change the
spelling of pictures and comics and a
handwriting implies that it's Joker but
what's really cool about this site is
that it's chaos and vandalism that is
breaking the fourth wall it's like the
Joker is vandalizing his own movie
trailer like he can't be contained
inside of a movie it reminds me a lot of
the graffiti ad campaign they did back
for the Dark Knight but to the other
cool thing about this whole bright neon
color thing the paint is actually almost
like a glow-in-the-dark thing and DC's
been called the studio that does the
dark superhero movies if you compare it
to the lighter fun of the Marvel movies
and I think that's exactly their point
here they're saying fine call us dark
but we will show you that we've got some
big ol freakin weirdos that will glow in
that darkness then as the singer of
Bohemian Rhapsody realizes that Judgment
Day has come for him
we see the guards come for dead shot and
this beating moment here it's actually
one of the first Oh just so perfect
times where the songs lined up with the
trailer this is happening just a few
cells away from boomerang cell so I'm
sure he's loving hearing all this also
the guy doing the beatings at Ike
Barinholtz format TV and the Mindy
project
he's clearly enjoying this and it's not
very subtle dat as far as he's concerned
he's the Alpha of this prison he also
seems like the main douche of this
prison let's move on was this
cheerleading tryouts the torture and
pain continued just a Freddie Mercury
complain
by the way again look how douchey alpha
who labels their raincoats like that
like what a freaking nerd we see that
he's been keeping out Diablo in a water
tank which I gotta wonder just how full
alpha lets it get and how much he makes
Diablo feel like he's drowning before he
lets him out but I guess it does kind of
make sense as the only way they can
contain a guy who can wield fire
honestly the real question is how did
they get him in there in the first place
we then see cross body a key moment as
he's wheeled into a creepy makeshift
operating room looking a lot like
another famous cannibal minor spoiler
here if you're not familiar with the
Suicide Squad and the comics are in
cartoon movie or anything but I bet this
might be where Amanda Waller has each
member implanted with a bomb and their
freakin head it's not much of a spoiler
though because how else did we expect
she was gonna keep these uncontrollable
villains under her thumb you do what she
says or she'll blow your freaking head
off Deadshot then gets off a mandatory
Will Smith one-liner was this a
cheerleader job which I think might be
what he says when he catches a glimpse
of Harley Quinn and her pigtails and
also I hope alphas coffee tastes like
crap okay then we get one of the best
moments of the trailer where Captain
Boomerang bursts out of a stack and
immediately attacks the guard the sack
looks like he actually might have been
shipped like mails all the way from
freaking Australia like they put a stamp
on him and sent him out like he's some
sort of like rabid kangaroo that they
just wanted to like get rid of Slipknot
also pulled a similar move though he
Dexter lady FBI agent so it's much lamer
and you can see amongst the guards is
rick flagg who is the team leader and a
kind of recruiter for the squad I'm also
taking a look at the way everyone's
dressed and that joke about this maybe
being try out and this feel like that
this is the moment where the team first
gets together I'm gonna go out on a limb
here and say that this might be a
Longest Yard moment if you're not
familiar with The Longest Yard it's a
movie about prison inmates who form a
football team to challenge the guards
and maybe even get to get even with them
and I could see that the squad members
maybe have to prove themselves worthy of
being on the team and they get to
challenge the prison guards in order to
prove themselves worthy maybe they fight
them maybe they all dupe like a big
rumble
which would be awesome actually maybe
someone even kicks alphas freaking teeth
in yes I'm sorry I know he's a fictional
character but I just like hate his guts
already for some reason by the way it's
pretty cool that this section wraps up
with who's super jag guys being super
aggro just to like show how dangerous
they are and then it cuts to Harley
Quinn just saying hi boys clearly she's
just as dangerous as them but in her own
way okay let's keep going good job
shoots people he's a crocodile he eats
people burns people you're possessed by
witch she's just crazy rick flagg
ignores a really flirty June moon slash
enchantress while giving us a team
breakdown as the Eclipse for the dossier
and the documents confirm that this
person is Belle Reve or if you're
pronouncing it the correct French way
Belle Reve and that's the same metahuman
containment prison from the comics and
you can find the name a little ironic
because the translation of it means
beautiful dream or maybe you're like
Harley and you actually think that it is
just a actual dream world
but anyway b-team Deadshot has perfect
aim cool a Killer Croc is a cannibal and
we see a second of him probably about to
eat a guard which by the way is kind of
their own fault for putting a deep pond
in a Cell Diablo has torch hands and
note what gets said about enchantress
you're possessed by a witch meaning that
he's talking about her in that moment
and since we don't see her in the prison
cells I'm guessing she joins the Suicide
Squad in a different way than everyone
else does I will still probably get her
origin story with those cave diving
scenes that we saw in the other video
and then finally Harley is just crazy
which I think actually might be her
superpower in a way and I think that
means if something's gonna happen in
this movie where Harley really earned
that title and just like the Joker in
the Dark Knight was an agent of chaos
I think Harley might pull something in
this movie that is just completely
unexpected and changes everything
maybe we'll see what was that I should
kill everyone and escape sorry
the voices I'm kidding is that what they
really said so this here is our clearest
shot of Scott Eastwood and we're not
really sure what character he's playing
yet it might be Deathstroke which would
be cool but it might be Dick Grayson the
robbing that people know and people
think maybe he'll be undercover in this
movie as an ex Robin and that would be
so freakin cool
but in this trailer at the least we know
he's some sort of soldier friend of Rick
flag still fingers crossed for
undercover robbing that would be so cool
also I'm gonna point out that it looks
like they all just arrived on these
Hannibal Lecter Sandeen Gurney's and one
more thing check out that smirk that
Will Smith makes after Harley tells her
joke prediction
I think Deadshot is totally gonna be
into Harley if you're wondering goodwill
Smith and Margot Robbie have any
chemistry at all check out focus and you
will see an adorably very talky sex
scene between them
maybe we'll get a sequel to that scene
in this movie save the world
okay then the trailer starts to pick up
speed so so will I cool thing that's
going on here Rick flag is laying out
the deal that the Suicide Squad has
found themselves in the terrible paddles
that are gonna happen we get glimpses of
that and it all just fits perfectly with
this part of Bohemian Rhapsody if the
operatic part that is supposed to
represent a trial these two side
fighting over the singers soul and the
stars of our movie are also fighting for
the redemption of their soul we've been
seed chinook helicopters getting fired
at over what looks like the Chicago
River but because they framed it this
way and it's a helicopter invasion and
it's purposely placed over water I think
this is a direct reference to the ride
of the Valkyries scene in Apocalypse Now
which was also referenced recently in
Star Wars also the gunfire is another
moment that's perfectly timed with the
music so good anyway then things derail
very quickly there's this wreckage that
some people say is a plane but some
other people think it could be one of
the choppers other people think it may
be a subway train that's like pushed up
from underground tell me what you think
it is in the comments then there's a
military Humvee that's been destroyed
and it's got this trail of this like
strange blueish green crystals crash
sure what that is but we'll get back to
it later anyway and then note this spray
paint tag on the Dunkin Donuts sign
that's a technique that the military
uses to label sectors of a town that
have suffered a huge tragedy sometimes
see them in a like zombie apocalypse
movie or actually in real life with
something like Hurricane Katrina and
some of the numbers tend to represent
things like how many dead bodies they
found there or other parts might
represent if the area is cleaned of
infection it's all just very creepy to
see also since that's a humbie and this
sign says no maybe like no we did not
clear it then that's a pretty epic thing
that the Suicide Squad is going into
after the United States military clearly
failed this shot then shows us the
lineup with Harley Quinn looking like a
kid in a candy store Rick Flagg Deadshot
El Diablo Captain Boomerang and katana
and it's not clear how katana is joining
the team she's kind of a good guy in the
comics and she's actually on arrow right
now in a kind of different way but Joel
Kinnaman has said that he sees katana is
kind of like a bodyguard to Rick Flagg
so maybe that's true and that's what she
is here but notice also Slipknot is not
there and while I feel like
he might be in some other moments around
this scene I still feel like you
shouldn't really get attached to this
guy if you know what I mean basically my
guess is the guy who is the superpower
is ropes he might not last very long the
group then invades what looks like an
office building but then we see a gross
subway platform that's like covered in
that same group crap from before and the
subway by the way it looks to be this
really famous Toronto subway station
called lower bay it's famous because it
was a real subway station in the 1960s
but they only left it open for six
months then they just completely shut it
down and let it dip they're closed
abandoned probably wanted and then
decades and decades later when Hollywood
was like hey can we use that abandoned
haunted subway please they totally
remodeled it from an abandoned crappy
subway to look exactly like a real New
York crappy subway actually really even
tagged it up with fake graffiti and now
you know some movie history in the next
few beats we see the exterior of the
station while Deadshot is trying to
maybe murder something Hartley's going
off on her own and Will Smith gets and
other Will Smith lines or save the world
which is still alway better than that
stupid other line from the other trailer
with some kind of Suicide Squad yes you
are that's the name of your movie thank
you
then Harley double fists a gun and a bat
and we get a rare shot of Will Smith
wearing his white mask don't count on
many of those because a list celebrities
are allergic to face masks then Captain
Boomerang fights one of those weird skin
creatures and oh my look at that he
looks like he might be trying to
decapitate him with a freaking boomerang
like I was actually pretty nervous that
there weren't a lot of boomerangs in
this trailer and I was like are they
avoiding showing it cuz it's gonna look
lame or something but he still got it
who's there ho typical Aussie weapon and
he is managing to make it look kind of
badass so maybe they pulled it off then
Killer Croc body slams one of these
creepy things and you can actually see
that it's wearing like a soldier's
uniform and on the way down you can see
that it's also got a soldier's gun so
I'm thinking this goon might be some
sort of like mind-control thing that's
essentially creating zombies but zombies
that can shoot guns and fight you and if
that's the case that is awesome sounding
also Harley blows that little tuft of
her hair and
just oh so adorable and you can make out
her little like pudding choker saying
you get a better shot of it later but
it's obviously a reference to the person
well you know who that's a reference to
speaking of mr. J I can't wait to show
you my toys
this section finally addresses the clown
in the room Jared Leto's Joker and while
this Joker definitely already looks to
be very different at least in appearance
than Heath Ledger's Joker scene this
moment reminds me so much of that Dark
Knight Joker scene where he's holding
Gamble's face kind of the same intensity
why so serious and that chaotic mind
also seems to be there I think I'm
actually starting to come around to
seeing this version of the Joker he
definitely looks freaking crazy and I
mean he's hanging out in a meat locker
so I guess an upset also I'm pretty sure
the guy who's holding it Ike Barinholtz
freakin douchey alpha guy you can see
like that brown hair and that goatee and
it's just good to see him getting what's
coming to him but you never know
actually what if Joker's actually maybe
creating a new villain out of this guy
kind of like he did with Harley there
were rumors that Ike Barinholtz could
maybe play Hugo Strange and while it
would be a really crazy different
version of that guy's story it could be
interesting if he's somehow survived
this and becomes another villain in this
universe think remember the one Batman
vs. Superman teaser that they showed
before it showed the Riddler symbol it's
clear that they're definitely willing to
keep adding characters to this universe
so you never know this guy might come
back we then see what looks like some
Joker foot soldiers wearing this
ridiculous masks as they shoot down a
hallway but it's mark Ward app meaning
that this shootout is in maybe a mental
hospital so probably Arkham Asylum and
the Joker is clearly taking it over then
the Joker appears in this tuxedo with
the white carnation thing and laughing
and he's firing probably the fanciest
looking gun I've ever seen but he's
appearance here hits all of reference to
Alex Ross's cover on Batman Harley Quinn
that comic which by the way is about
Harley Quinn's creation and is the first
comic to like officially bring the
character into the DC Canon in the
comics before that it was only a cartoon
based character actually it's starting
the cartoons first but considering that
on that cover Harley Quinn is right next
to him I'm wondering if she's about to
join him in this shot then the guy
shooting here his patch says mister FRA
so Johnny Frost probably he's a Joker's
henchmen slash like a driver but also
see his other patch says JSF which I'm
guessing stands for may be Joker
security for it anyway look at the free
gun that's a massive I think that might
be what is trying to take down those
helicopters and it totally could we then
get a glimpse of that scene where I'm
pretty sure Joker is starting his
torture of Harley Quinn and then he
makes her crazy then we get a great shot
of that badass Joker 'mobile and if you
want one it's actually just an affinity
q35 coupe with this Vader body kit now I
don't consider it's a spoiler because
this was in the other video that they
released but if you forgot this is the
moment where Batman shows up on top of
them and since you can see Harley Quinn
in there with Joker I think he actually
catches them here this is probably a
flashback and it's probably how a Harley
Quinn got put away in the first place
then we get a shot of enchantress in the
white house telling Amanda Waller let's
do something fun and Joker laughs his
ass off inside of a orbit of guns and
knives and champagne and normally I
actually kind of hate it when the bad
guy sets up this like elaborate scene
because then you have to imagine like if
he just really waste all that time
putting up all these pictures and I'm
talking right now definitely about the
movie Spectre but either way it doesn't
really matter here cuz I actually buy it
that the Joker is crazy enough to have
spent all this time to set this up also
that kind of looks like a flipped over
piano maybe wouldn't it be very
interesting if the coca just like breaks
out into a musical number it definitely
would be unexpected after an explosion
we see katana using her soul taker blade
and if you're good at the pause game
like we are you might notice the soul
that she's taking or has maybe taken
before supposedly her dead husband's
soul is in there somewhere too it's also
worth mentioning that this very creepy
section of the trailer is where we get
to the part of the song that says
obviously referencing Satan and demons
which the Joker an enchantress kind of
represent and that line means that the
singer slash narrator knows that his
soul is doomed just as we see the doomed
souls of katanas blade and oh my god
this song fits so perfectly the music
starts to ramp up into the rock and some
part of a human Rhapsody when Deadshot
loading his gun to the beat of the song
just totally showing off I guess amanda
waller and then it's the peak of this
like rollercoaster energy we get what
many are calling their favorite moment
of the trailer Captain Boomerang nailing
that Australian spirit of beer-drinking
but since there have actually been a
couple of pretty good Captain Boomerang
moments in this trailer you might be
wondering is he actually gonna be like a
really big deal in this movie and it
definitely feels like they're trying to
make him a fan favorite and considering
that he's typically a flash villain and
there is a flash movie coming out maybe
they're actually setting him up if he
does well with audiences to bring him
back in that movie I'll say so far so
good though I still think a lot of its
gonna depend on just how cool their
people to make throwing a boomerang look
speaking of the boomerangs you can see a
couple of them right there but either
way we'll have to wait and see if they
pull that boomerang thing off let's keep
going into the section of the trailer
where it starts and just become
genuinely one of the best edited
trailers of the year
man this is all kidding just so epic now
the guitar solo kicks in and we start
getting this insane barrage of shots
that are building up like a firework
grand finale and they go by really fast
so let's just try to fly through them
and see maybe what you might have missed
in there there's a close-up of katanas
eyes as they roll over black meaning
maybe she's absorbing souls or maybe
she's talking to them she has that power
too some people actually think that she
might be pulling a Loki and Hawkeye here
and maybe falling under some sort of
mind-control possibly under and contra
says mind control there's a lot of
options for black eyes also notice how
the mask has like a slash in the eye
area and it leads to a scar on her cheek
and scar through eye area that's always
the mark of a badass so I'm pretty
excited for katana now the Harlequin
does a kind of erotic dance while using
a chain like it's a shot guy but her
shotguns blast there really suddenly
time to match these cymbal crashes from
the song also check out the outfit she's
wearing it looks kind of familiar it's a
golden black version of a Harlequin
outfit which is obviously from seeing
her traditional red and black wine so at
least we're getting it in there
somewhere and honestly it looks pretty
good here a Black Hawk attack helicopter
it looks very cool but then because the
Joker's in this movie we got to have
amazing shots like this where there's a
freaking panda firing the assault rifle
I just love the way that looks by the
way it looks like this is also from
taking over article maybe then we get a
Scott Eastwood fist bump and please be
undercover Robin please be undercover
husband then the biggest mystery of the
whole freakin trailer this guy remember
the train station platform that was like
covered in crystals this is obviously
how that happened he rips through a
freaking subway train like a tin foil or
something and if we hit the enhance
button that we have you can see he's got
normal hands and he's maybe just a
normal dude that's in there and he kind
of looks like he's got a bald head and
tattoos maybe on his back that's all why
everyone's like this is probably
tattooed man the character that's
rumored to be played by comment then
when you look at another shot of them
and you hit the super enhance button
you're like hey they even do kind of
have similar facial features but this
character doesn't have
nose-ring he also doesn't have that
weird chin hair so maybe it's not
tattooed man actually there's another
theory that this could actually be the
demon Incubus that plays a big part in
Enchantress's story in the comics but
that's also kind of shaky maybe it's
that I know there's another character
whose name I'm just totally blanking on
who has these sort of like weird
appendages and you can also mind control
people by covering them in goo and stuff
and he's a perfect fit for this and I
don't remember what his name is if you
remember who I'm talking about tweeted
at me maybe at fimo so there's one I
can't remember
maybe it's Incubus maybe it's tattooed
man or maybe somebody else let me know
whoever he is he's not messing around he
looks freaking badass anyway moving on
there's a quick shot of Joker shoving
some sort of gun maybe a tranquilizer
gun into someone wearing a hair net
behind him there are some more henchmen
including Frost looking much more dapper
now but I actually prefer what these
other guys are wearing those are the
coolest mattes ever like somebody get me
one of those I love that freaking Chompy
face then there's a shot of Killer Croc
choking katana and honestly this is
probably a really dumb idea does anybody
else think that maybe katana is just
about to whip out soul taker and end
croc completely right now like the only
thing croc gets out of this is this
pretty cool looking shot of him which is
actually more impressive if you realize
that none of that is CGI everything
you're looking at right now is actually
totally practical effects and prosthetic
yes even those way too big nipples
moving on we get a quick shot of Harleen
Quinzel slamming down on something it
almost looks as she's trying to escape
from someone and then there's some
badass shots of dead shot using a
signature wrist gun oh and the cop car
that he climbs over that's our first
clear shot of the sign on the side and
it says Midway city police in the comics
Midway City is a kind of wannabe Chicago
but it's interesting to point out
because that means this is in New York
and it's not metropolis and it's not
Gotham it's Midway and those creepy
things that Deadshot is shooting at you
see what I mean about these guys looking
like zombies that can shoot guns and
super slickly jump over police cars and
stuff that's terrifying if zombies could
do that I love it I hope this is what is
happening here
oh and then maybe the best of the music
and trailer syncing up stuff the shell
casings are so perfectly timed with the
song
and there's a bed a shot of Harley
walking clearly having seen some action
because you got that cut on her head and
you can see her goodnight bat over her
shoulders and check out her arm tattoo
it's another reference to a traditional
costume and ok another shot of mystery
subway man and if this arm thing just
destroyed this pillar it is not going to
go well for these soldiers then there's
a shot of Cara Delevingne as June moon
probably before she's full-on
enchantress Joker's annoyed he's head
buddy in a car window I would say that
it looks like he's in the back of a
police car but it kind of looks like
this dude is just like chilling drinking
a beer so maybe it's not a police car
then there's a cool shot of El Diablo
torching something high up in a building
as Deadshot is totally like freaking out
behind him there's a quick insert of
Harley Quinn dancing back in that
nightclub and if you look closely you
can see the Joker is actually with her
there so maybe this is part of that
crazy night on the town that we saw a
little bit of earlier then there's this
creepy black bath thing that June moon
is in and I'm gonna bet that this is one
of those scenes where the characters
like very stressed cuz weird stuff keeps
happening to them and they're like I
just need to take a bath to clear my
head and she's like in there and she's
calm and she closes her eyes and when
she opens them boom there's like weird
grass crap and the waters all black and
she's like chilling under a freaking
pentagram I yeah you know what I'm
talking about we've all been there then
as her eyes roll up and boomerang looks
up we wrap this trailer hub with some of
the coolest shots actually in this
entire thing
seriously the hell's wrong with you
people for bad guys this is what we do
man weren't those shots right at the
beginning of that section awesome The
Joker Swan dives into the VAT of
chemicals and it's in slo-mo and I'm
guessing this is right after he's
probably pushed Harley Quinn in of
course comic book fans alike and that's
eight chemicals by the way which is the
place that the Joker was created and now
I guess Harley Quinn was created which
matches the new 52 origin but anyway did
you guys notice what's going on with the
chemical bathroom right now remember
Harleen was running around wearing a
blue shirt and Joker was just wearing
that like purple issue line so my guess
is the chemicals here are stripping the
color out from the clothes and those are
what stained Harley's hair you can see
it in a shot just from a second ago this
is also probably how she gets her skin
all bleached and white just like the
Joker's is so probably no luck on him
bleaching those tattoos away we can hope
though okay coolest thing about the
leaking color chemical stuff which by
the way those are the same colors that
are the neon colors of this trailer look
at the shape they're making it's a hard
oh the heart made of chemicals and
violence and it's just adorable then we
get some kind of fun kind of ten
pointing between Deadshot and rick flagg
who well they are actually gonna have
some power struggles in this movie then
there's another finger moment with Joker
wagging his back-and-forth in Arkham
then there's another moment where croc
is desperate to show off his weird
nipples for some reason and then there's
a freakin Chinook that falls out of the
sky and it crushes some cars and I
actually got a wonder maybe that's the
wreckage that we saw earlier in this
movie or maybe that's how the Suicide
Squad arrived which is a rough freaking
landing then Joker and Harley are back
in the car for a second and they're
joyriding and Deadshot again perfectly
timed that the music is beating the hell
out of what looks like his mattress I
think
then there's this really epic shot on
the front steps of the subway station
exterior and this crazy moment with this
weird mushroom cloud and the creepy
figure surrounding it and it's all
clearly sponsored by monster energy
drinks by the way if you're wondering
how the lyrics fit into this section
it's the part of the song where the
narrator's decided that even if they're
being sent to their death they're not
just gonna accept that they're gonna
fight to get out of the situation so yes
it still fits perfectly that's exactly
what the suicide squad is saying you
might be sending us to our deaths but
we're gonna try to fight our way out
Harley then loses her jacket and pulls a
Tarzan and then we get our second abrupt
cutting away of the music so that Harley
can abruptly stop the mission and steal
a purse based on the way flag is
reacting and the hush Ness and
nervousness that he gotta add I bet this
part of the movie has them landing in
that contaminated area or infected zone
or Ground Zero where they're gonna call
in this movie and now they're just all
super nervous and quiet because they're
worried about getting attacked really
soon by those zombie thing and then
someone makes like way too much noise
maybe the rocket launcher shot from
earlier and then BOOM zombies swarm it
actually kind of reminds me of when
they're trying to avoid the herds of
zombies I'm walking dead Oh also check
out Harley's jacket it says property of
Joker I kind of feel like Harley Quinn
might have some self-esteem issues so
this seems like exactly the right movie
slash mission for her to finally find
some self-esteem
those shirts by the way they translate
too if you want peace prepare for war
and it's actually a perfect motto for
Amanda Waller and her mission here with
Suicide Squad because it's kind of like
saying with you want an omelet you got
to break some eggs like yes sure
everyone wants the world to be safe and
good and happy and Amanda's gonna do it
her own way with a bunch of villains and
Psychopaths and violence and bombs in
people's head and if that motto applies
to you you can also buy the exact same
shirt and all these outfits there's a
link in the description to the store
where they sell this stuff the trailer
then wraps up with Freddie Mercury
singing the final words of the song
nothing really matters to me
which sum up perfectly the emotional
detachment and the anarchy of Harley
Quinn and all of the members of suicides
go up because ultimately it's a really
dark
song and it's a dark thought and it kind
of is being suicidal that's the result
of getting to the point where nothing
really matters to you these criminals
are at that point it's either they do
this and they probably die or they rot
in prison and definitely die so nothing
really matters to them they're all a
little suicidal and that makes them all
very detached but it also makes them all
very unpredictable and very dangerous
seriously who would have thought that
this song would have so many matching
themes to this movie okay so that was a
great trailer and unlike some of the
other ones with his team recently it
still leaves a lot to the imagination we
still don't know what the movie is
actually about we don't know who the
villain is still so just great job on
this editor's good job DC good job hi
Courtney even who knows you might be
charming in this movie I just can't wait
for this thing to come out I'm very
excited for it which is surprising I
didn't used to be that excited for this
movie and now I am so that's the mark of
a good trailer I'm very tired the
trailer wiped me the hell out so I'll
see you guys next time hit me up at fimo
if there's anything you want to talk
about in this if there's anything I left
out let everybody know in the comments
below if in the meantime hang in there
we got a lot of really interesting stuff
coming very soon I'll see you then in
those other videos bye